if you are married you can make all the
comments in the world if you're not in a
marriage just assuming that's how it
should be yeah
the response to that to that scenario is
this they should just compromise if if
it's an issue if that if it's that much
of an issue for her then she said don't
worry don't worry about it tonight but
yeah I'll wake you up in the right way
yeah yeah
I just agree I really think sex is a
duty I think you're supposed to listen
to your husband
wife too
listening
whenever you guys don't like everything
if you're gonna over talk me you're
gonna go yeah
thank you thank you oh my God I got to
see it live where's the camera send a
super chat right now so we give that
kick out cam